this video is made possible by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now go to brilliant dog slash bio
graphics you'll also find a link in the
description below we remember him for
the annual prizes that he gifted to the
world without Frid Nobel also left us
with another legacy explosives he was
the inventor of dynamite and it's even
more deadly incarnation gel ignite they
made him rich beyond his wildest dreams
but also left him with a tortured
conscience in this week's by graphics we
examine the life of Alfred Nobel Alfred
Bernhard Nobel was born on August the
21st 1833 in Stockholm in Sweden he was
a sickly child who almost died after the
first week of his birth as it was he was
one of just four of eight children to
survive his illness kept him indoors
while his three brothers played outside
Alfred's father Emmanuel was an inventor
and an engineer but he struggled to
realize his ambitions and as a result of
the family struggled to get by just
three months prior to Alfred's birth his
father had been forced to declare
bankruptcy and shut down his business
Emmanuel was now being chased by
creditors things became almost
unbearable when a fire ravaged the
family home help me against me to the
Nobel children were sent out into the
streets to sell matches alfred was an
extremely pallid and sickly child he
suffered from epileptic convulsions
along with a host of gastric diseases
and debilitating migraine headaches for
the first six years of his life alfred
was schooled by his mother he proved
himself to be a gifted student from the
start by the age of three he was able to
read from that time onward he was rarely
seen without a book in his hand he also
had an amazing memory when Alfred was
four years old his father moved to
Russia in order to pursue a business
venture Emmanuel had managed to get a
meeting with the chairman of the Tsar's
committee for the promotion of industry
and trade he steered the conversation
towards the land mines his area of
expertise and was able to secure an
invitation to Turku to meet some
influential people Emanuel worked in
Turkey for two years where he invented
the Prada
we know today as plywood he then moved
to some Petersburg there he was
introduced to Tsar Nicholas the first
seizing that the opportunity Emmanuel
told the Tsar about his plans to develop
a submerged explosive mine
Nicholas immediately saw the potential
to use the invention to prevent enemy
ships from entering into Russian waters
things all were now looking up for the
nobles with the money he received from
the Russian government as compensation
for his development of the submerged
explosive mine in manual setup a
mechanical workshop and armaments
Factory as well as making the new mined
the factory also produced industrial
tools and cannon shells in 1842 when
alfred was 9 years old
emmanuel sent for his family to join him
from stockholm the new life of the
nobles was vastly different to what they
had known in sweden there some
petersburg house was luxurious in
comparison to their old home emmanuel
was now able to hire a tutor for his
sons unlike his brothers alfred was
studious and intellectual he was also
intensely curious about the world around
him he loved the poetry of percy shelley
especially those concerned with the
subjects of nature and justice from
these readings he developed a deep
desire to stand up to injustice
Alfred's other loves were chemistry and
languages by the time he was 17 he could
speak five languages his father also
recognized in the boy and natural
affinity for solving problems marking
alfred as the most promising of his sons
to follow in his inventive steps the boy
loved nothing better than to spend his
time than his father's factory silently
taking in everything that his dad was
doing before long his father allowed him
to handle the chemicals himself alfred
stood has encouraged his passion for
chemistry and literature at the same
time they coaxed him to come out of his
shell socially largely as a result of
his ill health he was a painfully shy
and introverted boy yet with the help of
his tutors he began to stretch himself
academically in his mid-teens
he began participating in debating clubs
and started to share his passions with
family members then around the age of
fifteen he had a growth spurt which put
him at the height of most of his peers
this went a long way to boost his
confidence
in 1850 Emanuel paid for alfred study in
paris he had already been studying with
chemist and Nikolai is Sinan and it was
chemistry that he pursued in France in
Paris
Alfred spent time with Ascanius Brera
who had recently invented nitroglycerine
Sobrero was totally opposed to any
commercial use of his invention due to
its highly unpredictable explosive
potential in fact in later life he made
the following statement about his
invention when I think of all the
victims killed during nitroglycerin
explosions and the terrible havoc that
it wreaked which in all probability will
continue to occur in the future
I am almost ashamed to admit to being
its discoverer Sobrero is a version to
his discovery did not put off young
Nobel in fact the reverse was true the
substance fascinated Alfred Nobel or
sometta chemist by the name of Jules
Pelosi who was fascinated with a
nitroglycerin and had a determination to
bring it under control after a year in
France Alfred went to the United States
to pursue his studies there he worked
with Swedish inventor John Ericsson
Ericsson would go on to gain fame as the
inventor of ironclad warships used in
the Civil War as well as the inventor of
the screw propeller Erickson filled
Alfred's minds with dreams of what he
could do if he was able to tame the
nitroglycerine after a year in America
Alfred returned to San Petersburg his
family recognized a changed young man
his brother Ludvig recalled Alfred had
grown so that I hardly knew him he is
almost as tall as I and his voice has
become so deep and strong that I didn't
recognize it but Alfred did more than
change physically the young man who had
left with lots of ideas but little
Direction now had a goal to turn my
producer in into a commercially usable
blasting agent for use in tunnels and to
create fear-inspiring weapons of war
that was so terrible that nations would
be deterred from ever going to war in
the first place first though Alfred had
to come to the help of the family he
worked alongside his brothers in one of
his father's factories that the physical
work proved too much for his weakened
body
he was often too sick to work and on one
occasion in 1854 he became so unwell
that his father packed him off to the
spar town a friend
man to recuperate by now in Manuel's
business it was flourishing his
submerged explosive mine was in high
demand along with other munitions to
supply the Russian forces in fighting
the Crimean War of 1853 through 1856 by
1853 Emanuel was employing more than a
thousand people in his factories and the
Russian government was so pleased with
him that they awarded him the Imperial
gold medal in recognition of his
diligence and creative skill in Russian
industry in between overseeing his
manufacturing empire Emanuel found time
to collaborate with Alfred on the
nitroglycerin problem but even in manual
with his vast experience could not find
a safe way to detonate the substance the
end of the Crimean War in 1856 saw a
sharp downturn in business for the noble
company Emanuel was forced to change his
focus from armaments production to
churning out household and industrial
implements but still the business
suffered by 1859 Emanuel found himself
facing bankruptcy for the second time he
closed the factory liquidate his assets
and moved with his wife and youngest son
and mill back to Sweden Alfred and his
two older brothers Ludwig and Robert
stayed on in San Petersburg
twenty-eight-year-old Ludvig was given
the job of consolidating and running the
remnants of the nobles Russian operation
he rebranded the company as the Ludvig
noble mechanical Factory Alfred spent
about four hours each day helping out
with a family business the rest of the
day he worked on his passion to tame
nitroglycerin
[Music]
Alfred's first step was to learn to
create nitroglycerin himself by 1861 he
had accomplished that goal after
spending up to 18 hours a day in a small
factory building the first breakthrough
came when he discovered how to transport
a nitroglycerin safely by first soaking
it in coal dust
now suddenly nitroglycerine was a viable
explosive engineering companies from all
over the world came to the noble company
to purchase the products and the money
started rolling in Alfred's next
challenge was to find a safe way to
detonate the nitroglycerin in September
of 1864 though tragedy struck the
swedish noble company factory a vat of
nitroglycerin had been overheated in the
resulting explosion five people
killed including Alfred's younger
brother and mil Alfred himself was
working in the next building and he
suffered minor injuries in the disaster
rather than being put off from working
with nitroglycerin Alfred threw himself
into making the explosive safer to give
up now would be in his view to allow his
brother to have died in vain in 1865 he
built a factory in Hamburg Germany it so
happens that the soil around the Hamburg
factory was special it contained minut
particles of fossils when nitroglycerine
was poured into the soil it turns into a
doughy consistency this process in
effect puts the nitroglycerine to sleep
in order to wake it up the detonation
purposes and about invented the blasting
cap
Alfred knew that a fuse could not be
used directly to detonate nitroglycerine
but that gunpowder could be used to
detonate it a fuse could be used to
detonate the Gunpowder which would then
ignite the nitroglycerine by 1867 he had
mastered the use of small copper
capsules of mercury fulminate which was
ignited by a fuse to detonate the
nitroglycerin this blasting cap would
wake up the nitroglycerine which was
packed into a doughy soil base Nobel
calls the combination of nitroglycerine
blasting cap and soil dynamite Nobel
patented dynamite and began putting it
on the commercial market it was an
immediate success with engineers from
all over the world hammering to get
their hands on it virtually overnight
Alfred became rich beyond his wildest
dreams
we can get an idea of how much money
came in by an anecdote apparently true
concerning his housemaids wedding when
Alfred asked her what she would like as
a gift the various Stuttgart replied as
much as you make in a day the following
day Nobel gave her a check for $100,000
Alfred himself never married but he did
have at least three great loves
throughout his life while living in
Russia in his early 20s he fell for a
Russian girl by the name of Alexandria
painfully shy he finally built up the
gumption to tell the girl how he felt
about her
but his affections were roundly rejected
the rebuff hurt him badly and for the
next 20 years he refused to let his
heart be broken again Nobel consciously
portrayed himself as a hermit and an
eccentric he once wrote the following
about himself
I'm a misanthrope yet utterly
benevolence have more than one screw
loose yes a super idea list who digests
philosophy more efficiently than a food
even though he had money to purchase
literally anything he wanted alfred was
rather frugal this may have been a
reflection of the extreme poverty that
he had experienced in his childhood he
had no interest in purchasing such
tokens of wealth as elegant carriages
clothing or food but would invest
liberally in new estates and business
ventures Nobel was known to have a
temper it was a man who did not suffer
fools with many occasions being recorded
where he was rude with people usually
those who worked them he was get to the
point type of guy yet he also had the
ability to charm potential investors
when the need warranted it
[Music]
in 1876 alfred apparently tun out of his
life of solitude and placed an
advertisement in the newspaper that read
as follows
wealthy highly educated gentleman seeks
lady of mature age versed in languages
as secretary and supervisor of household
after interviewing a number of
applicants alfred employed a woman by
the name of bertha Kinski 33 year old
bertha was extremely attractive and
noble was immediately attracted to her
it was also taken with her obvious
intelligence and wit but that did not
return her employers affections in fact
she already had a fiance after a few
months probably feeling in the tease
with the situation she resigned as noble
secretary still the two remained friends
and they maintained an active letter
correspondence right up until the time
of nobles death she in fact became the
recipient of the Nobel Peace Prize in
1905 some weeks after Bertha left his
employee Nobel met a young woman by the
name of Sophie Hess despite the fact
that alfred was 43 and sophie was just
20 they entered into a relationship
there was to last for eighteen years
apparently embarrassed by the age gap
Nobel kept the relationship a secret
the age difference was not the only
thing that seemed to work against the
relationship sophie was uncouth
uneducated and ill-mannered their
relationship it was a toxic one in 1891
Sophie became pregnant to another man
but Alfred held out hope for their
relationship until she married the
child's father three years later even
then he sent her an annual allowance of
six thousand florins Nobel never had any
children despite his immense wealth he
filled his days with work often going
non-stop for 20 hours in 1875 he
invented gel ignite which proved to be a
safer explosive than dynamite in the
late 1860's alfred set up a number of
plants across Europe in the United
States in June of 1866 he started the
United States blasting oil company the
first nitro company in the US he also
spent increasing amounts of time and
money
protecting his patented inventions from
fraudsters who tried to make money off
his hard work
alfred was convinced that his invention
of dynamite would ultimately be good for
mankind
saying that my dynamite will sooner lead
to peace than a
thousand World conventions as soon as
men will find that in one instant hole
our knees can be utterly destroyed they
surely will abide in golden peace as
history has borne out his faith in
mankind it was sadly misplaced in 1869
while traveling in Florence no belt met
Paul barber graduate of the Ecole
Polytechnique barber who came from an
affluent family was fascinated with no
bells dynamite and proposed partnership
he offered to finance the production of
dynamite in France and told Nobel that
he wanted to learn how to produce
himself he had no bells interest mainly
because France was envied in the
industry for that state monopolies that
had held over explosives production the
two men came to an agreement by which
all profits would be split fifty-fifty
the French Enterprise was a success and
that soon expanded to factories in Spain
Switzerland in Italy in 1868 alfred set
his sights on establishing a dynamite
company in england he considered this to
be the prime location as it would open
up the entire british empire as his new
market he spent several months traveling
around britain's mining districts
looking for suitable factory locations
the best chances for investment came
from Scotland after much negotiation the
British dynamite company was formed in
1871 alfred purchased a four-story
mansion and estate in paris as well as a
greenhouse for his prized organs and
stables for his beloved horses the
estate it also had a private laboratory
for the next decade alfred spent the
bulk of his time working in this lab
along with his assistant of georges a
Ferren bark it was here that he
discovered what he considered to be
dynamite 2.0 gel ignite gel ignite was
not any more stable than dynamite a
calls the greater explosion and was
easier to shape overall the substance it
was simply much safer and easier to
handle than dynamite the new invention
was an even greater success than
dynamite and it caused even more money
to flow into the noble coffers in 1881
alfred grant dissatisfied with the
facilities in his paris mansion
laboratory he bought another estate this
one located some 15 miles from paris in
the town of sevran here he builds a
larger and better-equipped slab he based
himself in the town but ran into
problems with the French authorities
when he refused to comply with their new
regulations and policies which he
considered to be unnecessarily
restrictive amazingly the French
government charged him with high crimes
and treason he was forced to close
new lab and he left for Italy the French
government forbade him from ever working
in their country again prior to his
ouster from France Alfred had been
working on his latest invention ballast
tight he continued this work at his new
lab in San Remo in Italy Palestine was a
smokeless propellants that combines
nitrocellulose and nitroglycerine the
rights to the new explosive were leased
to the Italian government who began
using the m18 nine zero Vettel II rifles
which used cartridges that were loaded
with ballasts tight Alfred's brother
Ludvig died in 1888 the newspapers
however reported that it was the far
more famous Alfred who had passed away
as a result Snowbell had the rare
experience of reading his own obituary
what he read it shocked him to his core
virtually every newspaper that he looked
at seemed to glory and his supposed
demise
one French headline announced the
merchant of death is dead another report
stated dr. Alfred Nobel the mutilator
who became rich by finding ways to kill
more people faster than ever before died
yesterday Nobel was devastated at the
realization that the end result of his
life's work was to be worldwide
condemnation he decided that he had to
do something to turn around his
reputation and whatever time he had left
in 1893 alfred employed a personal
assistant by the name of Ragnar Solman
and appointed him as the executor of his
will the two men worked diligently on
the documents over the next two years
then on November the 27th 1895 Alfred
signs the will of the Swedish Norwegian
club in Paris it was a will like no
other Alfred left 94 percent of his
total wealth the equivalent of 265
million 2018 dollars to the awarding of
a number of annual prizes to individuals
who according to the will during the
preceding year have conferred the
greatest benefit on mankind the will
spelled out five categories physics
medicine chemistry literature and peace
the Peace Prize was to be given to the
person who has done the most or best
work for fraternity between the nations
and abolition or reduction of standing
armies and the formation and spreading
of peace congresses today there is a
sixth
agree economics that this was not added
until the end of the 20th century
[Music]
in his late 50s no girls health was
increasingly causing him problems his
heart was especially weak in an attempts
to self-medicate he began administering
doses of nitroglycerin this quite likely
contributed to his deteriorating state
his body finally gave out on December
the 10th 1896 following a stroke he was
63 years of age Nobel Prizes began to be
awarded five years later so today's
video is a great example of how science
can be used for both good and for bad
and Alfred Nobel is not alone in his
position in history as someone who used
science to create something truly
devastating but if we cannot understand
him we cannot hope to control it and
when it comes to understanding science
there's really no better place to do
that than at brilliance they are a
learning platform which teaches you
through something called active learning
basically this means that instead of
staring at some text and complicated
diagrams and equations you solve
problems actively I've been using
brilliant to get a feel of how this
works and it's a bit like this I don't
know that sitting down when I was a
student looking at a textbook and
reading a paragraph and then having no
idea what really happens I'd go back
over it again and again and I'd still
not really get it or I'd get it a little
what brilliant has absolutely none of
that each thing you read is immediately
applied I chose a random topic in
brilliant as an example for this message
and in five minutes I understood what
vectors scalars and displacement were in
physics it's pretty crazy because if
those were just written down in a
paragraph like I mentioned before I'd
just be like maybe with what now it
would make no sense this is why
brilliant is so great if you like
learning and I'm gonna guess you are
because you're watching a channel like
this one you will love brilliance it's
such a good way to master complex
scientific concepts
do you support bio graphics and to learn
more about brilliance please go to
brilliant dot org slash bar graphics and
sign up for free also the first 200
people to go through that link will get
20% off the premium annual subscription
so as always I really hope you've
enjoyed that video if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and as
always I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you